I was watching a video last night of
some Utah lawmakers that were musically
explaining how a bill becomes a law
that's what the song is about right
Travis how a bill becomes a law that's
right that's right fun right so they
basically wanted to take that premise of
Schoolhouse Rock you know I'm juste
debout but moving into 2018 and do
something that would relate to the young
people that would get them excited so
they put it in a song form they put it
in a song for him yeah
current song uh it's it's a rap they did
it's a it's a rap they did white guys
rapping some girls also white right
right older older they're not so much
young people themselves they decided
that they would do the rap themselves
and what they thought would be really
fun is if they did it to the theme of
like a current rap song and they went
with The Fresh Prince of bel-air Channel
well yeah the title of the song is
actually The Fresh Prince PR INTs Fresh
Prince of bills here because Bill's here
in bel-air is almost the same thing
right yeah very similar very yeah it's
pretty close I mean if you were gonna go
what now we'll get it just change one
word that's what you would do Bill's
here Fresh Prince of bills here that's
right
and if there's one thing that the kids
of 2018 know about it's the Fresh Prince
of bel-air yeah right how much your kid
he's seven oh so he's probably just
starting to get into the Fresh Prince
right and he's never heard of it
is that right it's weird he doesn't even
know who Will Smith is huh yeah that's
weird cuz Fresh Prince came out and what
1991 I want to say ninety yeah that I
mean you would think that it would still
relate to the kids thirty years later
I'm surprised I mean this might be to
current they probably should
done like the Gunsmoke theme oh you
could just get some young kid like those
parkland kids you know just go on TV a
local Utah
TV and just say hey this is how to
billa's and they could explain it that
way you try to explain it like an 18
year old kid right yeah just hate it
break it down he doesn't have to rap
doesn't have to rap you don't have to
have mid 30 it's not me no no no we're
talking forties and fifties so forties
and fits so middle-aged women and men
white men well hey this will be fun
we're gonna lighten up the situation
we're gonna do it in a fun way here's
there's a lot of heaviness in politics
these days and they wanted to make make
it a little lighter - maybe - maybe to
show kids that politics aren't quite as
scary as they think they are okay you
know and that's positive that's a good
thing that's gonna stop natural
disasters from happening you know but
that's that's a good thing do you want
to hear the song yeah I'm just curious
out how many hits it has on YouTube well
it's not on it's on they put it out on
Twitter and the thing that we're looking
at it's got 54,000 views which is a lot
for Utah especially because it's only
got 11 thousand followers right well you
know what it is that's that's 54,000
radio shows across the country all
talking about this playing this song in
a positive way no we got material for
tomorrow that's really happy yeah when
when I saw this yesterday I was really
happy that I had it for tomorrow and
then I was really happy that you were
coming it's like this is exactly what I
want to play for Florentine okay yeah
let's you want to hear a little bit yes
yeah we're showing the court houses and
everything
[Music]
this is a story all about okay hip highs
that's as far as I got
that me too I've not heard the rest I
couldn't do it anymore
it doesn't rhyme when I heard chambers
like nope yeah yeah it rhyme yeah it's
not in time at all it's edited poorly
because they went from person to person
and so far I think they went we might
have to go back to the beginning because
they went to three people and all three
of them are on a different rhythm and
none of their lyrics rhyme with each
other it's almost like they tried to get
it sounds like they tried to get lyrics
to rhyme with the original song but but
they don't rhyme with each other like
this it doesn't rhyme at all does it no
I'm very rarely embarrassed to be white
but in these moments like I don't want
to be lumped in with this this isn't
because that really is I mean there
there is a population of people that are
gonna go like this is what happens when
white people try to be cool yeah that's
what that look what I'm gonna use an
example I'm like no no no that's not us
yeah I don't that doesn't represent me
please that does not now I know how my
certain minorities and different
ethnicities feel when they see negative
stereotypes and they go that does not
represent me that is not who I am
like I'm not criminal I'm not that I
feel that way when I see this this
doesn't represent me right as a white
American that this isn't I don't stand
by this at all but we all only seen a
couple a little bit of it that's true it
could get better
[Music]
this is a story all about how Lady Jane
bear did you just start it away too soon
right Troy you're a musician what the
hell is going on it's just like they
just decided to start at a random time
they should when they do it they should
probably play the beat somewhere in the
background so they could sort of do it
in time oh my god you're so right they
just gave them lyrics and said hey wrap
this lyric right we'll just come by your
desk wrap this lyric and then we got a
piece of together we'll put it on with
music it's not nothing nobody's mites
properly everybody sounds completely
different you can hear the room noise
and each one is completely different
it's like they made it with iPhones but
different iPhones for every person and
they all have different phones yeah is
where they spend most of their days I
love this like this douche bag with the
yellow with the yellow flower on his
jacket first of all you can tell he's
the guy with the personality in the
office because he's got his purple shirt
on and he's got his patterned tie in a
striped suit like yeah he's the funny
one right like he's like whoa he takes
fashion risks yeah you know what I mean
he comes to work like oh let's what's
his name Mike let's see what come what
color shirt do you think Mike's gonna
have on today well Mike is today a
purple day and he just comes around oh
yeah you know me you're and they have
the the company picnic or they all go on
a Saturdays they're all getting together
with their families he's gonna wear
something goofy right and he brings a
six-pack of beer whoa I didn't know is
that kind of party Mike's like hey you
said it was a party
I brought a six-pack think 30 people
there he's like I got the six-pack I
have
in the law book is where they spend most
of their day max know what introducing
bills inside of House chambers guy I
thought that the guy before him was the
most embarrassing guy just because there
were so many syllables in his lyric but
the the commitment the commitment to the
guy that just he was like what was and
introducing all then I was in chambers
like what's he talking about they didn't
even try to rhyme that one no and now
introducing bills inside of House
chambers you see that guy's showing off
his autograph Donald Trump hat I saw him
what to steal our helmet okay yeah he
was holding a Steeler oh yeah yeah and
he's wearing a make America great hat
again and he's cut down on Trump what
did he just take all the tchotchkes in
his office and just pile it just pile up
all my tchotchkes on all all this stuff
it's do you guys mind if I show a little
personality in the video a little flair
yeah do you guys mind if I bring some of
this Flair look at the way we wearing
that hat he doesn't wear hats I know
it's not even snug on his head no he's
trying not to mess up his hair is
probably unfamiliar he recited his lyric
I'm making changes in committee on the
hill they may get one in the fight but
it's just cut as they care they say were
and we'll argue it there it's reading
like a nursery rhyme they say we're
moving it back to the floor and we'll
deal with it there it just puts everyone
else off time completely that's why they
had to start this thing so early because
there's a couple these really old people
that are just reading it like a poem and
they can't fit it in yeah that got that
last guy yeah he was terrible yeah timey
is not a concern no no they don't they
don't miss parody they don't care and
they're there sitting there going like
oh it's no big deal it's just a little
local thing for the Utah people 54,000
views later and it's only gonna go up
today it's only gonna go up hotdog are
you offended by this guy you're looking
at him right now is that offensive to
you this is really embarrassing there's
now a guy who's making like white guy
gang hand gestures but it's really just
the Aloha bro
it's hang loose yeah hang low Sonny's
got the hat on
he's got a took his tie off you can tell
he was wearing a tie yeah because it's
all [ __ ] up right because his collar
it's not like casual kind of down he
unbuttoned the top button but it's
clearly been button the entire day and
his collars all [ __ ] up cuz he pulled
his tie off and then he he put a
baseball hat on sideways he put no team
on it but he put a baseball hat on
sideways because he's like this is what
rappers do I'm gonna be a rapper in this
video it wasn't her part I think black
people in Utah are watching this video
going we're not represented but there's
no be representing us at all the one
yeah one black guy in Utah is like this
way they told me not to move here this
is why they told me I shouldn't be here
this is it this is literally this is
like the real-life version of get out
this is this is this is real life hot
dog I know that your your your Dominican
but you but do you do you see white
people as this they're you like this is
this is white people this is this is how
they can see all you guys like it's just
reinforcing stereotypes just imagine
these people have kids imaginary oh my
god the sons in high school
yeah and they gotta go to school and
their parent is in this doing this [ __ ]
you think snot you think you think one
of the key the key one of the kids in
school dressed up in a suit with a with
a sideways hat on and said hey buddy I'm
your dad if that was me like my dad did
that I'd have an easier time explaining
why my dad was all that kind of sex
offenders website yeah yeah I don't mean
like yeah well you know I just made a
mistake the girl hey no hey Jim can you
go drunk hey Jim can you go can you and
your dad come trick-or-treating with us
no my dad can't trigger yeah it was an
incident years ago we had a few drinks
and yeah the girl looked down oh she had
a lot of makeup on but you know he was
drunk and he didn't know right Jim is
that your dad in this video no that'd be
more about right this would be tougher
to explain so you're not you would you
would disown your father for this yes
but the sex offender list you would be
like all right people make mistakes you
make mistakes this is something of a
usable yeah yeah what about what about
like some of these guys are young they
have little babies one day that baby's
gonna grow up and find this video
internet lasts forever they're gonna be
like what they're probably gonna have
respect like let's say this Jim okay
you're a little baby right you grow up
with your dad you have respect for your
dad you're like that's my hero that's my
dad you're now sixteen sixteen years
you've spent you didn't even go into the
[ __ ] phase of being a kid sixteen
years you spent your dad is your hero
and one day you just get this video in
the email and you see that 16 years ago
when you were just a little baby this is
what your dad was doing what do you do
I'd rather find out that he wasn't my
real dad at 16 that my uncle really bang
my mom and I'm real it was his brother
that'd be easier than the easier than
this yeah I'd be like I look you know
all right
you know families have weird fucked-up
[ __ ] sometimes yeah but not this
alright go on not quite there we stop so
many times I think it's only fair to see
if it actually flows when you just
listen to it you know yeah I mean but
that is of course it doesn't flow we
keep stopping it what did you think of
the end Troy what the hell is going on
why is that guy stick his tongue out
like that cuz that's what rappers do hey
son I did one of those wrappings you
like I guess you could call me MC cool
dad and that you know to make it fun
like it but like the video wasn't fun
enough at the end e6 is tongue a leg out
now it's really fun right and let's uh
let's let's leave the laughter in at the
end just so everybody knows what a good
time yeah yeah we really did have a good
time yeah let's make sure that there's a
little bit of laughter at the end so
people know we were just we were just
horsing around yeah
do you wanted to see the whole thing
start to finish to see if it flows it
might flow we were stopping it a lot
it's unfair yeah I think also Florentine
can you explain to me how a bill becomes
a law based on this song no all right
then we need to hear it I mean even
probably get your oh yeah I mean so in a
minute 16 we got this okay
hot dogs dancing
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
and now introducing bills inside of
chambers I got we might disturb the
beginning again because that guy I can't
I can't get enough of that guy go back
to the guy again
the ball guy yeah the ball guy it's yeah
I think it he's my favorite I can't get
enough of him and I'll introduce him
Bill's inside of house chambers can you
I wish I wish I could get that audio
without the music behind it I would just
play it non-stop I don't think we can
but still if somebody pulled me that
audio I don't know if I needed in the
intro or if I need it I think I need
maybe I needed on the intro and on my
sound board I was just thinking about
just making this the intro might be
better than the other stuff we have now
I mean this is this is fun and it and it
teaches us before I think we do have to
start from the beginning let's go to
James and Texas before we do what's up
James yeah guys see I'm from the streets
yeah and it's actually starting to make
sense to me I'm actually learning so
much about laws and you know House
chambers right chamber is a secret but
that's because you know whenever I read
it in the book
but when I hear it to that beat that's
like you know just gets real real deep
into my brain because you're from the
streets yeah I mean it's the only way
you can get through here cuz im so hard
core I see I see thank you James that I
see it is it is making a difference Dave
in Kansas City good morning Jim Sam
welcome back toy I think this is not
actually from Utah I think it's from Los
Angeles this has got to be Covino and
rich no no this is
I don't think this is a Covino enriched
song this is a this is the the Utah
local government doing this you don't
think that they say chain bears in Los
Angeles maybe they do I don't know thank
you Dave I don't know but I know I it
doesn't
I know Covino and rich and that doesn't
it doesn't look like them singing all
right let's start from being a start the
second verse so early that it [ __ ]
everything up afterwards but they have
to start the second verse that early
because of the of the two really old
people that come in and just start
reading it like dr. Seuss they don't
have any choice because otherwise the
lyrics could go way past the beep and
Troy I would imagine as a music producer
my assumption that the people who put
this together don't know a ton about
looping theirs don't know anything about
keeping lyrics in time right I think
it's just literally like they didn't do
the raps to time at all they probably
just gave him a sheet and said wrap it
like this they're like all right we
won't be on time but we'll get the
message out that's right and if you know
like the lyrics of The Fresh Prince song
you can clearly see that each lyric is
mimicking the lyric to the song but they
add in a whole bunch of more words yeah
that don't rhyme that don't rhyme so
it's just like and you can't can't do
that it doesn't make any sense
all right we should start from the
beginning because I I know cuz I stopped
because no because it's team bears guy
okay
[Music]
this is a story on the hill and the
answer is clear look thing is lunch on
his tongue still tongue didn't look
clean like green [ __ ] on it it was good
when you put it all together it's like
ah Jim can you tell me how long's made
no I still can't know it's so weird you
see in the one yeah I was trying to keep
you know follow along but I just
couldn't so I think I'm just gonna
google it and I could probably find out
maybe that yeah you see when you want
you see the guy who just walks onto the
shot so many hearts yeah I I and I
didn't really hear it until like that
time we were listening in the beginning
we were just like there's that that
happens twice or different sounds yeah
there's also when the old guy when he's
just talking right he just sounds like
there's a vacuum going on back him going
on when he's talking let's go back to
the old guy that's just talking cuz I
know exactly you're talking about that's
the guy whose fault it is that
everybody's off time because he took
forever to get his lyric out it's the
one who's sitting down right that guy
yeah yeah yeah who just takes a we're
moving
listen our view up there now is a
vacuum-cleaner Cohen they decided not to
wait yeah I mean how long does it take
to vacuum probably 10 minutes maybe yeah
okay you just say hey hang on one second
we want to record something shut the
vacuum off for a second or wait ten
minutes and be like listed in ten
minutes when they're done either one of
those two options would work but they
didn't want to do that
they just wanted to get the lyrics done
I don't even think that was even a
concern no no I didn't think all this
noise will affect the way that the
sounds know the message will get across
just fine and the kids will like it
they're probably thinking like oh you
know be great if we could actually get
like iTunes to put it up is there like a
real song you know we could have because
musically it works how do you convince
all these people that this is a great
idea you derrin just so many dorks in
the world there are just so many people
that you're like oh yeah we're gonna
wrap a thing and they think it's like
1990 and that's like Oh wrap Oh wrap is
cool you know let's do it yeah someone
yeah the boss decided that this was
gonna be good good way to get it out
there to relate to the young people and
then everyone's like alright yeah sure
I'll do it yeah give me a line no that's
funny alright I'll say this one oh yeah
Dave's doing it oh yeah I'll do it too
okay yeah yeah well we got probably ins
and Democrats oh oh cool yeah that's
great I'll do it but I want to stick my
tongue out ah no I think that was
natural that was just that guy moment
because it was so fun he was going off
the cuff exactly you could tell how much
fun these guys aren't by how much but
each one of them has like what five
seconds of camera time just one lyric of
one rap song for five seconds and half
of them are losing their minds like
they've never done anything like this
before yeah so embarrassing there's
nothing redeeming and just every second
of this thing did we tweet out the video
either way let's make sure the video and
you notice there's no black people in
this video at all could not one if there
was somebody there to go I'm not doing
that there's no way I'm not being a part
of that no no man I'm gonna lose my
street cred I'm losing it just by
hanging out with you people
can I look at the dailies what are the
clips that you've gotten so far I'll
show you on my phone like these are some
of the other lyrics and you just be like
one of these I'm not doing them I'm not
doing that
there's no chain and what's it called
The Fresh Prince of of I don't remember
what the title something of bills here
yeah I'm not doing that yeah you know he
turned it down it's like I can't be part
of that right there's one guy and I
think I can't do that we need you though
cuz you know that they wanted one black
guy in there then it would be all white
again a couple of women and then and
then so he just said one guy decided
I'll put a hat on backwards and then you
know do like the gang signs kind of like
hang loose hang loose yeah so I'll yeah
so that would be just the same thing
that'd be yeah that's cool so we'll do
that I'll take my tie off to to make it
look like gum he's probably thinking to
himself I'm tired of people think then
the white guys aren't cool I'm gonna
show him how cool white guys can be what
guys in Utah white guys in Utah he's
taking the black guy role he's right
okay I'll be the guy - yeah I'm probably
like okay if we're not gonna have the
black guy in here I'm probably the
coolest of the white guys right so Dobb
got yeah I'll get my son's hat right
yeah he's probably got like kids and
he's like don't worry I know what the
kids are into turns his head sideways
these are the same politicians that are
like we're gonna try to outlaw baggy
jeans it's like you idiot nobody even
where's baggy jeans yeah name it in
style anymore Miguel in Los Angeles
what's that me go amen you know it was
anything that we learned
yeah I've one of them there's a really
big dick and puts it out on Twitter then
people will probably be like actually
that sounds pretty good but yeah you're
right Miguel they kind of figure out
yeah hey Jim um wait why do you have a
problem with Juwanna who you wanna suck
dude I was trying to think I'm like did
I do something I'm thinking yeah who do
I know
Juwanna
did I say something Robin Oklahoma hey
Jim
hey Jimmy Sam I was just gonna see if
maybe they could do a remix of the
faceplant intro song if they if you want
so you want you like the faceplant song
but you want the politicians of Utah to
sing it yeah yeah I think maybe add a
little hip-hop where they I'm a white
person myself and you know white hip-hop
is very popular I would say probably
better than the other hip-hop as many
awards as we win with it right you know
you know just add a little hip-hop
player I think you're right Thank You
Rob I think that's a great point
oh good one of the people that is being
represented by that video
Don calling in from Utah these are these
are Don's representatives make you so is
he gonna okay's these all he's on the
phone he's on the phone yeah is he gonna
rap or any talks or he's just gonna talk
yeah Don I don't know how does Utah
handle it are you just gonna talk or do
you wanna do you want us to put on a
beat for you Don you there hello hey Don
we were just we were just wondering if
you want us to put on a beat for you so
you can wrap your phone call you just
want to talk because you're from Utah
[Laughter]
these are your representatives these are
the people go on well you know Utah
Mormons they're kind of kind of little
weird and I thought they you know maybe
they just thought they were funny at the
time
I think you did know that was so
embarrassing man I was still
embarrassing I'm ready to pack my stuff
and do sorry you know you don't have one
of those guys you know he'll be in
Starbucks today and someone coats
comfortable hey I saw you in that video
it's like oh really like he's all
excited and he's like yeah why would you
do that what were you thinking there's a
hundred and four members of the Utah
Legislature yes there's one black woman
no black men oh really
that's why then and I think Sandra
wanted to be a part of this yeah they
were like Sandra we really we really
haven't asked for you and it's actually
really important we really need you for
this one you think no I'm not no there's
absolutely no chance now if they didn't
invite her to do what you think she's
gonna [ __ ]
saying hey they did this thing without
me and you know it's discrimination
because I'm black
that's a tricky one because then you'd
have to say you did because if you say
it's discrimination and I should have
been asked because I'm black then it's
like you're admitting that all black
people rap and only black people rap
like you can't think now you're cashing
in on the stereotype to claim
discrimination like that would something
maybe she would but then when she saw
the finished product Rose I don't even
want to I didn't want people offense and
I'd want it to be in that yeah she was
probably insulted at first she was like
what the d'Ovidio without me and I'm the
only black woman I'm the only black
person in this whole state that's a
representative and they're doing her
it's a wrap she heard it's a wrap and
she probably like watched all the Fresh
Prince episodes and everything she's
like I'm more familiar with that
shouldn't than any of these guys and
then she turns on the video and she's
like oh thank god oh thank Jesus oh my
did not tweet it she did not know or she
read the lyrics like these are lyrics
we're gonna do if you want to pick a
verse in that great something is
empowering for the culture as Black
Panther comes out and then two weeks
later they're like here's this though
here you go this is still this is what's
out there you thought we progressed yeah
I just want to let you guys know we're
not in Wakanda like in 1994 this would
be all right and how all white people
want to be silly and right 1994 this
would it would have been corny but it'll
cut what a kind of work there's a lot
there was more of this in 94 well yeah
in 2018 we're looking at this going like
why the [ __ ] would you do that
in the 1994 like every white comic had a
rap at the end of his write at the end
of his bit like that was his closing
thing did you ever you never did that no
no no those always a white guy do me and
Norton be in the back of room
we'd watch - just wait till the end to
watch it just but every white guy had
like you know I'm a goofy white guy I
don't know how to rap that kind of thing
right that was everyone's closer but
that was 99
for uh-oh we have one of the stars from
the video Mike in Utah is calling in
really he's one of the representatives
from the video it says here Mike yo yo
what's up hey Mike what's going on man
I'm dropping them hot vs. didn't you
understand
the lyrics are fitting to try to make
you understand how a bill becomes a law
no and a lot of the message was lost on
everybody here okay check that again
alright my god I'll uh I'll make sure
that all of us here check ourselves
before we wreck our say Mike which
[ __ ] were you in the video thank you
later fun guy yeah that's just Mike
would it be great if like they thought
this was a good thing and one of those
guys like thought that he was clearly
like oh yeah that video is really bad
except I actually did a pretty good job
rapping and they start like kind of
adopting some of it like yeah you know
these guys they didn't know how to spin
yeah
what how do what spin you know drop
rhymes you think they're gonna start
referring to it as the chain' bear yeah
yeah one guy's not gonna realize that
this has become viral and everybody's
making fun of it and he's just gonna
walk in and go who's ready to drop some
laws have been this chain bear and
everybody turns around and looks at him
because it's a total disaster you didn't
hear let's go to Bob in Chicago what's
that Bob guys two things first of all
I'm a team bear you're rapping in my
[ __ ] house of representatives my head
commander in my [ __ ] his house
applause if this is how they actually
explain it then probably that's a great
point Bob like that this video is
effective because you know how bills
become laws
nobody does it's too complicated it's a
bunch of people talking [ __ ]
nobody understands any of it it's it's
completely [ __ ] up and that's why this
video is a perfect representation of it
probably right let's go to ban in
Wisconsin hey fellas
Damian if people in this country can
decide their own gender I am changing my
ethnicity I'm no longer white where are
you [ __ ] the box for other oh you're
just going to become another yeah I'm
not anymore
what are you gonna do my skin color oh
[Laughter]
I'm sorry Ben all right just a non the
white community yeah this is not good
yeah we should I hope I hope that
everybody in that video gets put under
fire for cultural appropriation although
they won't you know why because black
people will be like that's not our
culture yeah we got nothing to do it
that's all you white people that's all
you yeah you're right this is this is an
embarrassment for for white people this
is bad
this is probably gonna take us out of
the majority to tell you the truth it's
probably it for white people I think and
honestly if that's the product we're
putting out it should be that should be
it
we've had our raven black rappers got a
look at that guy I got a retired can't
rap anymore I don't want to be
associated you think it's so bad rap as
we all Anya's gonna go look I so does
then I'm done the me ghosts are gonna
watch that video and go we can't I'm
done we can't do this they're gonna
start just learning how to play guitar
and stuff yeah we got to get out of the
business we got to do something I don't
want to be linked to this yeah I got to
learn how to paint because this isn't
for me anymore
somebody somebody replying to their post
like yeah they posted hits yet the worst
part and I didn't even notice this the
worst part is not the rap which is bad
it's that someone legitimately thought
using Comic Sans was cool oh my god they
use Comic Sans all the lyrics are in
comics and I didn't even realize that
that's like Comic Sans is like the one
font that everybody makes fun of if
you're gonna make fun of a font right if
you're that type
person it's Comic Sans every time it's a
goof font and they actually and they
think girls used in the 90s on AIM they
did not use Comic Sans ironically no
this is like a time warp that's so
[ __ ] crazy are we sure this video
wasn't made in 93 like everyone's dead
and they just decided to post it yes
that is crazy the Comic Sans is making
me feel like somebody brought this back
in some kind of a time machine or
something
cuz this is weird well maybe you tossed
it I want to go to Utah now that place
has got to be so backwards oh my god
Salt Lake City is a beautiful I don't
know what happened yeah so bad for those
people maybe it's just salt maybe it's
one of those things where Salt Lake City
is like a great city but everything
outside of Salt Lake City is like
[ __ ] Ville yeah you know beekman's
comic [ __ ] sans with this video Comic
Sans oh my god I can't but that's how
bad the video is none of us picked up on
the font yeah that's how bad the video
is we could dissect this for another
three hours easily easily I could make a
career out of dissecting this baby yeah
I still want to know what those noises
in the beginning can we go back in here
the noises again yeah for a second I
thought I kept getting eaten email
that's that's so I mean I'm gonna say
something Troy and I don't normally say
this those noises that you hear in that
video not operator error right that is
not operator error but I keep every time
I hear that when the lady speaks that
noise happens I keep thinking I'm oh I'm
got an email right that's here
[Music]
this is a story all about how like
something this is being done on film
yeah like like that that it that sounded
like you right yeah
that sounded like when you have like a
strip of of mag tape that you put with a
film like it's a 16 millimeter film roll
and you have to line them up together
and that Boop is so you know where to
cut it down on [ __ ] phones like what
is that sound
OOP the guy before this has that like
wrestling picture in the background you
know no one like it like he's a guy and
yeah go back cuz they had that at the
gun the odd couple back in a day was
always that picture in the back rows I
see that oh and the boxing thing is that
a boxing thing yeah it looks like it you
ever picture yeah that's just like hey
um it's one to tell him he's got a cool
football oh you like sports wait looks
athletic too pill to pens in his pocket
not one but no pocket protector this
guy's dangerous yeah yes in case one
runs out of ink he wanted to make sure
you see the the pens so he has his his
jacket over so you could be like hey
look I'm wacky I have to color different
colors yeah sometimes I write in green
pen guys I'm that come though I'm the
fun I'm the fun representative I mean we
could really dissect frame-by-frame and
analyze it like this a prude or felt it
really is true this is the most
funneling video I've ever seen every
single frame of this video is just a
complete brain [ __ ] every frame of it
doesn't make any sense
alright let's hear the other noise sound
like a doorbell
yeah but she's in an office I think
somebody's outside like she's wrapping
into a phone who's ringing the doorbell
outside her office because someone
walking by goes ever is everything okay
in there
Oh what are you doing I heard
rapping yeah well she had a computer
volume way up and got an email maybe
maybe that's an email sound but they
didn't think to go like oh eight hon
there was a noise let's let's do that
line again yeah I know it's gonna take
forever to redo this three seconds but
you know actually let's just keep it
you're busy you got to pass laws in Utah
[Music]
you know you know I don't know I still
for me it's the ball guy no it's the
ball guy all day every day you know what
I you know what I can't believe right
now let's listen the ball guy in real
quick yep I could listen to him all day
you know what's amazing
what's even more humiliating than all
these people that wrapped they had to
get other representatives to shoot b
roll for this all the frames in between
the lyrics all these frames have guys
pretending to pass laws and looking at
books and going like oh this is crazy
they had to convince people to shoot b
roll yeah like those three guys going
you know arguing yeah was something good
two thumbs up don't worry we're not
gonna use the sound so you guys can say
whatever you want but just give me a
thumbs up at the end
yep pretend you're arguing over a bill
and then you then you figure it out and
you all give it a thumbs up did those
guys not make the cut were they not good
enough rappers were they not as good as
some of these other people maybe they
picked out the best guys that were okay
we need some passion here like you're
really fighting over this bill yeah oh
it's so bad dude it is so bad Jesse in
Toronto
hey Jim and Sam amen
I just wanted to see maybe if you guys
could go up to shady shade 45 and get a
real rapper to rap to these lyrics maybe
it's not the lyrics maybe the lyrics can
be twisted it may huh hey Troy do you
think you could find a rapper to do it
redo this song this is such a
[ __ ] lyrically or does it is it
too bad for your reputations pretty bad